recently i was scrolling the internet
and i came across a clip of ted cruz on
a podcast now ted cruz controversial
figure in politics but he was
specifically talking about bitcoin and
authoritarians and i gotta say ted cruz
absolutely nailed it here's the clip
that i saw and then i'll let you know
exactly what i think about it these
authoritarians
hate
bitcoin and they hate crypto and it's
for the same reason why do they hate joe
rogan because they can't control him
he's not subject to to their
authoritarian power why do they hate
bitcoin because they can't control it it
is a system of currency outside of the
monopoly control of the us government
and and i got to say as i've addressed
uh you know i spoke at a big crypto
conference in in austin several months
ago and i said listen you need to
understand
this administration i believe is going
to go after you and is going to try to
destroy you
and by the way
that's a pattern of authoritarians china
communist china
outlawed bitcoin
for the exact same reason why does
elizabeth warren hate bitcoin for the
same reason that she and china hates
bitcoin because neither one of them can
control it and and and the theme through
all of this is is the power of freedom
to be not subject to the arbitrary whims
of those in government power now that's
an incredible viewpoint coming from a
sitting u.s politician of course bitcoin
is a decentralized open protocol it is
outside the system no one controls it
and no one can change it without more
than 51 percent of people agreeing to
the changes that's how a democratic free
market system should operate but any
time that we have a politician sitting
and comparing an authoritarian
government like china with other u.s
sitting politicians you got to sit up
and ask yourself what is going on
and of course he's got a point that
there's plenty of people around the
world both within the united states and
internationally that don't like bitcoin
because they can't control it regardless
of what you think about wall street and
the banks politicians and governments
are real cozy with the people who
control money but all of a sudden when
you have a system that no one controls
they get really scared that ends up
upending how their model of the world
works bitcoin liberates citizens from
having to worry about what their
government's gonna do next there no
longer is a variable monetary policy
they can't debase your currency they
can't steal your wealth through
inflation bitcoin has a programmatic
monetary policy it's predictable it's
independent no one controls it and any
authoritarian government any politician
that has built their career on cozying
up to the banks they're screwed bitcoin
is inevitable and millions and millions
of people around the world are
continuing to adopt it ted cruz gets it
and my guess is that every politician is
eventually going to be forced to become
pro bitcoin